pour nous aider à mieux comprendre
gérald et là bon soir céline alors si
une décision peut dire historique ça
fait quand même près de 10 ans mais ça
marque vraiment une cassure lé entre les
états unis et le canada
absolument quand on regarde ce qui s'est
passé ce qui se passe aux etats unis est
ce qui se passe au canada il ya vraiment
une cassure la réserve fédérale a
vraiment préparé le terrain pour cette
hausse de taux d'intérêt avec justement
depuis la fin de 2008 un taux à zéro
c'est très rare de voir une situation
comme celle-là au plancher la réserve
fédérale d'injecter des milliers de
milliards de dollars dans l'économie en
même temps que le gouvernement à
injecter de l'argent et donc à retirer
ensuite graduellement cet argent pour
préparer finalement la hausse de taux
d'intérêt qui arrive aujourd'hui dans un
contexte donc de croissance économique
pendant ce temps-là au canada on parle
de possiblement baisser les taux en 2016
on s'inquiète de l'endettement des
ménages on resserre les règles
hypothécaires on parle de zones à
risques immobilière dans certains
marchés vancouver et toronto
la situation est complètement différent
mais alors comment expliquer justement
qu'une telle différents trois choses le
canada compte beaucoup sur les
ressources naturelles c'est 20 % de
notre pib notre économie n'est peut-être
pas assez diversifiée par rapport à ce
qu'on voit aux états unis deuxièmement
le gouvernement américain je vous disais
a beaucoup investi dans son économie
les etats unis connaissent l'une des
plus fortes croissances dans les pays
riches depuis 2011 et le marché du
travail américain est assez flexible la
conductivité l'effort mais il ya de
grandes inégalités
mais néanmoins on est en croissance si
on peut commencer à augmenter les taux
d'intérêts aujourd'hui une annonce
importante a eu des effets sur les
marchés envolée des bourses qui
reçoivent bien la vision de la réserve
fédérale et notre dollar canadien qui
perd encore quelques plumes aujourd'hui
toujours à 72,5 américaine jour clair
merci beaucoup pour moi